Life in the microcosmos is tough for its unicellular
residents.
Prokaryotes and protists have to compete for
food and space while also trying to avoid
organisms that are more than happy to see
all of their complex, energy-filled biological
bits as an afternoon snack, and managing those
tasks can be even more daunting when you are
very, very small.
So instead of facing all these challenges
alone, many of these organisms treat survival
as a team effort.
As cells divide, they adhere to one another,
building a colony that becomes larger and
larger with every cell division.
An individual cell can only get so big before
its size comes at the expense of other abilities.
But a colony can get much bigger, providing
protection against predators and a competitive
advantage when it comes to finding space and
food.
And as the cells come together and organize,
a colony can enable organisms to do so much
more than they could on their own.
It’s an advantage that became a vital step
on the path not just to more complexity in
the microcosmos, but also a vital step on
the path to us.
But before we get to that, let’s check out
this long green thing cutting across the screen.
Maybe it looks like a blade of grass, rudely
floating in everybody’s way.
But if you look closer, you can see thin filaments
made up of individual cells of a freshwater
cyanobacteria called Aphanizomenon.
Often times the names of these organisms are
really a pain to say, but Aphanizomenon is
just a joy.
If these cells were on their own, they’d
basically be little balls of candy just waiting
to get chomped but these long grass-like structures
make it harder for filter feeders like water
flea to eat the Aphanizomenon colony.
In lakes and ponds, these grassy structures can
accumulate, creating dense, visible blooms that release
toxins into the water.
Nostoc colonies are also made up of filaments,
like a string of beads, where the beads are
cyanobacteria.
But where Aphanizomenon likes to keep its
strands elongated, Nostoc wraps its filaments
around a structure made mostly of different
types of sugar that it excretes to create
a round, gelatinous mass.
These colonies vary in size, but some particularly
large ones have been measured with a diameter
of 22 cm.
I realize I said that like 22cm is very big,
but it is when you’re talking about a colony
of single-celled organisms.
Nostoc use sunlight to make their food.
But in the process, they also produce oxygen.
This is a problem because Nostoc also likes
to fix nitrogen from the air to make necessary
chemicals , and oxygen interferes with a key
step in that process.
But living in a colony means that some of
the Nostoc cells can specialize, developing
a thicker exterior that prevents oxygen from
getting inside the cell.
These specialized cells are called heterocysts,
and they can focus on fixing nitrogen without
any worries of intruding oxygen, while the
rest of the colony can continue photosynthesizing.
Bacteria aren’t the only species that form
colonies.
These spiked, circular creatures are Pseudopediastrum
boryanum.
The colonies are flat, and the cells are arranged
in concentric circles around each other.
Where the Aphanizomenon and Nostoc colonies
we showed earlier seemed to be full of cells
strung together, the Pseudopediastrum colonies
are usually made up of 8,16, or 32 cells,
whose walls contain sporopollenin, a hardy
material that protects the cells from the
environment.
The gold algae Synura also forms colonies,
with individual cells coming together like
little yellow marigolds.
Each cell is encased in silica scales and
has two whip-like structures called flagella,
which tumble the colony through water.
When Synuras bloom, they can turn a whole
pond yellow, letting off a smell that is somewhat
hard to describe, but even if you can’t
see the pond, you’ll definitely be able
to smell it.
This Gonium colony is made up of several flagellated
cells arranged in a sphere.
It may look simpler compared to some of the
other colonies we’ve seen, but with the
rest of its volvocine algae relatives, it
may hold answers to how multicellular life
evolved.
Members of this genus are either unicellular
or form colonies that, through evolution,
have increased in complexity from species
to species, like this Eudorina colony, whose
structure is more complex when compared to
its predecessors.
Like Gonium, the Eudorina colony is made up
of only one type of cell, repeated around
its surface.
But these colonies created the structure that
would serve as the evolutionary stepping stone
for a species just on the edge of multicellular,
Pleodorina, which contains specialized reproductive
cells, and then ultimately to the definitely
multi-cellular Volvox algae.
Like the colonies before it, Volvox is built
around a gooey transparent matrix.
And like Pleodorina, it contains a set of
specialized reproductive cells, just a tad
bit more specialized.
Those smaller green spots are somatic cells,
or body cells.
they don’t reproduce or divide, and one
of their main jobs is to help move the colony
using their flagella.
But after a few days, when their duty is done,
those cells die.
Meanwhile, on the inside are the larger gonidia
cells, which drive asexual reproduction and
might be immortal.
Now remember the Nostoc colonies that we talked
about before?
They also had elements of specialization,
with some cells devoted to nitrogen fixing
and others devoted to photosynthesis.
The difference between Nostoc and Volvox however,
is that Volvox reproduces by creating multi-cellular
daughters inside of it.
The gonidia cells divide creating a kind of
baby volvox with all of the somatic cells
and gonidia cells it will need as it matures.
It’s an organism inside an organism, and
when they’re released, it is not cell division,
it’s is birth.
Another example of how, when you look very
very close, every sharp line turns out to
be blurry.
The colonies that assemble in the microcosmos
are important, not just for the survival of
the organisms that comprise them, but to us and our own understanding of how our own multicellular
existence came into being.
Whether bacteria or algae, the way these colonies
come together and the shapes they take on
can be as distinctive as the individual organisms
they’re made of.
They make life in the microcosmos just that
much more complex, forming the foundations
for multicellular life both under the microscope and beyond.
Thank you for coming on this journey with us.
If you want to see more from our Master of Microscopes, James
check out Jam and Germs on Instagram.
And if you want a new video like this in your subscription box every week,
there's gotta be a subscribe button somewhere nearby.